Hi, I’m Thomas
One of the things I love most about film as
a medium is that a filmmaker can use the visual
language of film let you see the progression
of the story.
Like this moment in The Godfather, where Michael
has to make a phone call about his father.
This phone call ends up being the incident
that will change things for Michael forever,
and his physical separation from his girlfriend
Kay as he makes the call foreshadows the relational
separation that begins at this moment.
It never has to be called attention to, or
stated explicitly, and the audience might
not even notice it, but subconsciously it
reinforces the story visually.
But the Godfather isn’t the Al Pacino film
I’m going to talk about in this video, let’s
take a look at The Panic In Needle Park and
how it uses a tryptych to mark the major progressions
in the story.
The Panic in Needle Park follows the story
of Helen, a homeless girl whos friendship
and romance with Bobby leads her into heroin
addiction.
Spoilers ahead.
Director Jerry Schatzberg uses three key shots
to bookmark each major moment in the arc of
the story.
In the first we see Helen alone on the train.
This shot establishes for us her problem,
she’s on her own, and unlike the people
crowded around her moments before, she has
nowhere to go, nowhere to be.
Then Helen meets Bobby, and their relationship
solves some of her problems but she eventually
gives in to the temptation of the constant
exposure and availability of heroin.
Then we get the second key shot towards the
middle of the film.
We can see the closeness of their relationship,
and the seriousness of her decision to step
fully into Bobby’s world.
It shows us how their romantic relationship
inseparably linked to Helen’s drug use.
We see her shame, and Bobby’s dread as he
envisions the future.
And how in a tragic way, now that she’s
using, they can finally share a big part of
Bobby’s life, and they’re closer than
they’ve ever been.
But the story doesn’t end there.
As the film progresses their drug use starts
to supersede their relationship.
And in a final attempt to escape from heroin
and by extension Bobby, Helen ends up betraying
him and ratting him out to the police.
The final shot alludes to the finality of
this progression.
As Helen chases Bobby, it’s clear that any
remnant of love has long been overshadowed
by the damage heroin has done to their relationship.
Helen seeks forgiveness for her betrayal but
as her relationship with Bobby became inseparable
from her relationship to heroin, we realize
her reunion with Bobby probably means her
return to using.
When you look at all the shots together as
a triptych you can see the whole arc of the
story.
Helen is drawn to Bobby out of love, that
love leads her to drug use, and finally they’re
together but no semblance of love remains,
their relationship is both destroyed and held
together by their mutual need for a fix.
When I think of The Panic in Needle Park,
I think of these three shots.
They dug into my brain and didn’t let go.
What makes these three shots stick out?
The first key shot is a long shot that holds
after a series of a few shorter shots, this
combined with its focus on a single subject
amidst turmoil and motion causes the moment
to stick in the minds of the viewer.
The second shot is also a longer shot, but
it most obviously signals to the audience
the significance but cutting from a very wide
angle to an extreme close up.
This shot is the closest the camera has ever
been to their faces together, it’s the most
intimate moment we experience between them.
To further emphasize this particular moment
the noise of the street falls away.
The final shot starts with an empty frame,
and then reveals the two characters we’ve
been focused on and care about, slowly answering
the question we all have in our minds.
What will happen to Bobby and Helen, will
their relationship work out?
Notice how what clues we get towards the answer
come from the blocking of the scene.
It’s a long shot, and when it cuts to black,
the image of the two of them together sticks
in your mind.
You can form triptychs like this from other
films as well.
Returning to The Godfather, we can use three
key shots to show the main arc of the story.
Often the memorable shots from a film are
memorable simply because they looked cool.
But what if you can use single shots to give
your audience signposts along the way.
A movie is experienced linearly as you watch
it and all at once as you remember it, and
I think good directors know how to craft a
film that will be powerful both as you experience
it, and as you think back over it in the hours
and days after watching it.